let's jump to this story though from the
AP
US soccer equalizes pay in Milestone
with women and men they say the U.S
soccer Federation reached a milestone
agreement to pay its men and women teams
equally making the American national
governing body the first in the sport to
promise both sexes matching money oh boy
so this is why I think this is crazy
Lydia they have different pay structures
they're different leagues it would be
like imagine if Burger King announced
that they were going to be paying
McDonald's employees the same rates so
my question
they cut the men's salary yeah it's just
like yeah all right so are they taking
funds that uh were generated by the
men's division and giving them to the
women's division because the women's
division can't make enough to pay them
what they pay them in yes I think that's
what it is so it says U.S women and
men's team agree historically to share
World Cup prize money
so uh that is very that is very
insulting
we are generating yeah so so I think the
AP was wrong what what the story is at
least from the guardian is that they're
going to share each other's prize money
with each other so are they saying that
the women should be dependent upon men's
money I find that interesting so the
best thing are going to be giving
providers I guess yes the men are going
to give up large you know Millions upon
millions in the the female athletes are
gonna give up hundreds of thousands so
why would men play for the the US team
why wouldn't they just go play in Europe
and make a lot of money and not play on
the national team at all the interesting
part about this is is that the men's
team is actually trash relative to other
men's soccer teams and are for sure no
our female soccer team is one of the
best in the world right still men's
soccer
yeah exactly but it's number one so it's
for America first right now then we
should be rooting for our women's team I
mean yeah for them but they're still
generating less money so why should they
get more yeah we should support them too
we should buy what was it I mean if
people want to support
why aren't you dying your hair purple
just to get like Megan wrapping I did go
to activation in New York City well
there was a parade yeah when they won a
few years ago the people who want us to
play the parade the people who want to
support the women seem like they can
watch people can get invested in this
without having to take from the men's
team and it's funny because you
mentioned the men's team is not that
good I don't follow sports but I've
heard that but it's not as if anyone's
saying well you know we should be giving
the trophies that the women win to the
men's team because we just like men more
what we're saying is if a group of
people earn a certain amount of money
they should get that amount of money and
if a group of people earns less than
that you don't redistribute it to make
them feel better
especially when they're making money
playing sports they have a dream job
they're an athlete you do and you're in
a communist yeah great it's a socialist
soccer team yeah yeah you know it's
funny which makes sense because it is a
European sport right no one's not
American I love when the the the blue
checkies journalists were like the women
actually win and the men end up the men
are getting paid more money and it's
like the men negotiate a different pay
structure that was literally it well
there's also different audiences there
were bonuses or guarantees and the women
want to guarantees the men wanted
bonuses or something so it's like the
man got bonus money and made money and
the women didn't or something but but
also yeah it's just like imagine someone
working at McDonald's and they're like
this McDonald makes a million dollars
per month and then across the streets of
Burger King's only making like 500 000
per month so the Burger King employees
get angry and go on strike it's not fair
that McDonald's employees get paid more
than us it's like you're different
businesses I get you both sell
cheeseburgers but you're different
businesses so then they agree to share
their salaries like okay sure I guess so
yeah that doesn't make any sense at all
either
so do like if the men win they have to
give money to the women or something I
think they're going to be less
incentivized to win you're not making as
much money team's gonna do even worse
less incentivized to play on this team
so wait hold on well you said the men's
team is really bad so does that mean the
men aren't going to win and aren't going
to make money and so the women's team
isn't going to end up making this money
from the men anyway I think it's more
MRI
the the the the people supporting women
here they're men's rights activists who
think well what if we get alimony what
if we got uh trans women to fail the
women's league instead
but they would have to I guess we could
right well I'm sorry are they trying to
exclude trans women from their space so
the issue that I had with the uh well
the question is are there any trans
women on the women's soccer team we
don't even know that and if there are
well maybe clearly bigotry obviously
true yeah well I mean you know the
argument from the left on this is uh
again you know the Amazing Atheist
tweeted at me that you know tall people
are better at basketball we don't ban
tall people and it's like okay so then
for what reason don't we just like seek
out only trans women to play in the WNBA
who are going to be taller or in women's
soccer who are on average going to be
substantially taller and have more bone
density and muscle mass
the the point I was bringing up with the
skateboarding thing is that people like
to mention strength you know it's like
in in swimming your strength matters
your strength and endurance matters and
uh but in skateboarder doesn't in
skateboarding it is control it is timing
and the advantage of having a higher
center of gravity of having you know
narrower hips no matter what you do or
change that that's not gonna have an
impact I'm wondering if in the Escape
contest I don't think they have any um
uh hormone requirement like some some
sport leagues do where it's like you got
your testosterone has to be a certain
level because that wouldn't matter
anyway in which case my point is
are we gonna come to the point where if
the argument is based on gender as a
social construct and not sex
then someone who's literally a six foot
six 250 pound muscular male could just
be like
I'm a woman like zooby right when zooby
did the deadlift and said he was a woman
why not
that that should be completely
permissible under their ideology yes yes
in which case the women's I gotta say
why how about for women's soccer we
should get a bunch of males and I'm not
saying this disparagingly or or as I got
you it's a real question I think I think
you're just being inclusive Tim well no
no but in all seriousness if the goal of
the team is to win money the goal of the
team is to win contests The the we want
the brand to succeed and the coaches
want the best team possible then they
should have open tryouts and just bring
on the best possible people that that
there are and if the team ends up being
90 trans women we'll just we'll win more
good right I'm curious as to when we're
going to see an actual big backlash from
women on this actual issue as it becomes
more common because there aren't that
many trans women in these Sports yet but
as we continue to age you know the the
youth I think it's something like 20 to
30 percent of the youth nowadays um
considers themselves some form of lgbtq
yeah here's an issue though there's a
there's a lot of problems with early
medicalization
for trans-identified Youth
and this was this was sort of
interesting recently a mom reached out
to me
um and helped me to at a talk that was
given by Dr Marcy Bowers at Duke
University who is trans and has
performed some 2000 like trans surgeries
and the trans doctor performing the
trend surgery right okay and has
performed these surgeries on young
people has also prescribed the puberty
blocking drugs the loopron as well as
the cross-sex hormones if a child goes
on puberty blockers and then goes
directly on to cross-sex hormones and
does not go through natural puberty they
will have they will never orgasm
they will never have full sexual
function or or the emotional or the
emotional aspect additionally if you're
a little boy and you go on a puberty
blocker and then you start taking
estrogen you will never have enough
genital material to be converted into
the you know wound that is then referred
to as the neo-vagina that will also not
work additionally if you are a young
person and you start taking cross-sex
hormones you're going to have
substantial problems with bone density
yeah blood coagulation all of these
things so the odds that you're going to
be able to play sports are remarkably
small because you're just not going to
have the physical capability to do that
so if a young man go doesn't go through
natal doesn't go through natural puberty
he's not going to be able to play
against Megan Rapinoe anyone who does
that to a child belongs in jail I I
think it's the one that's happening in
how many states now it's uh what is it
Florida
um I think Iowa maybe Florida there was
Iowa
um is it Oklahoma
Texas I know there's a couple of states
where it's it's illegal they'll they'll
take the kids from the parents right and
then they actually ended up
investigating it was Ken Paxton's office
um and it was actually inspired by Libs
of tick tock uh which lives of tick tock
I talked to her about it and she was
like that was amazing like I actually
helped you know
um but what was interesting is the
Attorney General's office then found
themselves investigating a a parent who
worked at Texas Social Services
for uh medically transitioning their
child
I think one of the great lies one of the
big lies in among trans activists
obviously beyond that men can actually
become women and women can actually
become men is that these puberty
blockers have no consequences and that
we have fully studied their unintended
consequences we're right now giving
puberty blockers that were supposed to
be used to treat I forgot what exact
hormonal diseases but we don't fully
understand what these puberty blockers
do when used in the case of gender
dysphoria in children it's not good
studies aren't done and it's not
completely reversible at all
there are consequences yeah that it's
reversible there's like yeah but this is
the argument yeah because also you know
once once a person goes once a child
goes on those those puberty Lupron right
which is uh supposed to address
precocious puberty and then you take the
child off but in the in cases of healthy
children you go on it they put you on it
and then you immediately transition to
cross-ex hormones so you don't don't and
most kids who go on the puberty blockers
do go on to take the cross-sex hormones
because they're already believing it so
it's not a pause button it's an
initiation yeah
yeah
um the thing is you can't exactly tell
when somebody is going on hormone
blockers so it's hard to visibly see how
many people are doing it but what I do
see as somebody who's from New York City
Brooklyn specifically one of the most
trans parts of the city is that double
mastectomies are relatively common this
isn't something that like you don't see
or hear about from friends or friends or
C you see it people yeah it's relatively
common and I think that too convincing
women that the right move or whatever
you're dealing with interpersonal women
deal with a lot of issues mentally going
through puberty
Etc but to convince them to get double
Miss activities to to remove their
breasts again I think is a form is
comparable to modern day lobotomies yeah
and not just women girls I mean children
two people who are underage it happens
to the girls I wanna they're just kids
if I may just one thing they they talk
about how
um you know they tell kids if you're not
comfortable in your own body then
perhaps you're trans and I think it's
important for people to realize that uh
it's not really that normal to be
comfortable in your own body like bodies
are super uncomfortable especially
during and especially during puberty
puberty sucks for everybody like it
feels weird and yucky to have your body
change I know personally like I was 18
before I realized that I should wear a
bra and it was my it was my college
roommate who was like you really need to
do this and I was like ew gross I don't
really want to be involved in this oh
you guys are all embarrassed that's
really cute
I mean I never realized
I was I was horrified by being by like
being a grown woman I was like this is
really uncomfortable for a minute it's
called the Bro
right isn't that uh didn't Kramer do
that on Seinfeld no it was George's dad
that's right no he got he wanted the
manzier the manzier but he had teamed up
with uh remember one of the Bros that's
right yeah he's like no and they were
arguing about it
bro so let's throw it back to eugenics
in the early 1900s
when we had Matt bender on the on the
show I like that segue well it's because
it's the idea that progressives aren't
always right they think they are they
think they always win but that's not
true Sheamus made a good point he said
every you said every instance in U.S
history where someone has tried to to
deny personhood to another group of
people they've always lost something
like that right yeah and no group of
people who has ever made the distinction
between human and person and said it's
technically a human but not a person has
ever been on the right side of history
when we examine the situation later so
you look back at Eugenics and we've
we've done away with that it's like a
bad idea nobody likes that yet the you
know tenants of it still exist like uh
when we had Matt bender on the show he
was saying he was he kept saying over
and over again if a baby was born with
deformity of abnormality you wouldn't be
in favor of of you know ending its life
and I'm like no and he was like shocked
by that and I'm like I'm not into
Eugenics right like if if a human being
is born different we want it to try and
live if you're what an ableist view that
is and it's crazy but disabled here's
the issue genetic diversity is important
to the health of any species this is
basic science it's it's observable if we
start saying these traits are
undesirable where does it end and I'm
not going to oh slippery slope no no
quite literally you have parents being
like oh he's got a heart issue perhaps
they're going to look at the DNA and
they're going to say
when he's in his 30s he may experience
this so let's try again like okay and
then like you're gonna move the needle
more and more until at what point are
you arguing that it's just designer
babies and at what point do you do you
end up with a disease that primarily
affects people with a specific Gene you
know or or specific cell receptor and
then all of a sudden it's like we didn't
realize that homogenizing the gene pool
was going to result in in population
collapse but here we are so I'm just
like you don't do that also well Tim I
mean the left is actually uh disproven
the slippery slope they showed us it's
actually just a cliff I mean you you go
right over instantly
whatever disabilities I'm trying to look
up the exact Source because I remember
this in the past but what I'm reading
right now from the Atlantic is that in
Denmark they actually do tests to see if
the child does have Down syndrome
according to what I'm reading it says
nearly all expecting mothers choose to
take the test of those who get a Down
syndrome diagnosis more than 95 choose
to abort so this isn't just some fantasy
they've eliminated it you know a
scenario that we're talking about this
is actually yeah the thing too is like
you get to decide right like they have
all of these uh because I was older when
I had my son I was like 35 when I was
pregnant and there's all these tests
that they can give you uh that give you
like you know if he's gonna have
whatever there's something about X's I
don't really know but there were a ton
of them and they were like oh you need
to take this and this and this and I was
like why and they were like you know
because it'll tell you if your child has
a deformity and I was like I'm I'm good
I don't care I don't need any of that I
think there is an argument that will be
made about I'm not saying abort children
who have Down syndrome but there is some
version of equality of Life argument but
I do think the argument starts to become
is where do you draw the line to to
where you abort a child I'm not saying
it's okay or not okay for Down syndrome
but you know if we keep moving the
needle or the line it's like well if
your kid has diabetes you know do we
potentially want to abort him because
what if they're short yeah yeah what if
they're short what if they're going to
have male pattern baldness
the end of so many great and very
important people that's right right when
all the parents would have to do is
bestow a beanie upon them exactly so uh
I gotta say I like a beanie Lydia pull
up the story where it talks about
um what is this um Prater Willy syndrome
and it says Studies have found its
positive results are incorrect more than
90 of the time yeah yes I read about
this I think we wrote about this a while
back and it is absolutely insane because
the the genetic testing is not always
correct you want to talk about the death
penalty being wrong what 25 of the time
I want to talk about this test and why
people I'm against all of it I'm almost
abortion I'm against the death penalty
I'm against youth in Asia against all of
it this is an important Point like when
we're talking about the death penalty
there's an argument to be made all right
well like 75 of time of the time or
whatever that person's guilty whether
you agree with the death penalty or not
if the number is 25 but whether a child
has Down syndrome or not they're
innocent it it's wrong to kill them so
when people are horrified because they
go oh my gosh all these children died
who didn't even have the disease that I
think it's okay to kill people with
they're getting it backwards you just
should not kill unborn children yeah
when we were talking with Matt he it was
just it it man it was kind of crazy
when he was like you said you would
stand with those who wanted to ban
abortion and I was like I said if my
option was you who wants to legalize
elective abortion at nine months or
standing with the people who had been it
I will stand with the people who will
ban it that's how yeah because that
reduces the amount of death yes but he
didn't understand and he was like you
you just want to ban abortion it's like
no but that's what they're told that's
what they tell themselves they have to
say Tim it has to be for a lot of the
way some people view you it has to be
that black and white that's why you have
to be right-wing in that dude's eyes
it's so good you know but it was funny
because it was like two it was like a
progressive and a liberal argument over
abortion and the people who are watching
who are conservative are like these
people are far left everybody's insane I
know right like I'm like I'm I'm
pro-choice and he was like I what I
asked him and he said that he thought
the woman can choose to abort the baby
at nine months and I'm like that's not
you Deliverance like the people in the
middle always also get called the
opposite of whatever side so for example
like if you're a 14 weaker pro-lifers
are calling you pro-choice but
pro-choicers are calling a 14-weeker
relatively pro-life right wing 100 yeah
like if you're not up until nine months
then you're essentially pro-life look at
the conversation we had with Matt yeah I
mean but I think like Pro pro-life and
pro-choice is a dichotomy right like
you're either in favor of legal abortion
or against it I realize that there are
some people who are in favor of it at
different stages or against at a
different stages but like ultimately
it's like it's a binary like you're
either okay with abortion or you're not
that's why at timcast.com we say
pro-abortion or anti-abortion yeah
because pro-choice and pro-life are just
stupid buzzwords it's right like like he
Matt says he's pro-choice but not for
men so it's like what do you mean he's
not pro-choice for men women have the
right to make a financial decision to
kill a baby but a man doesn't have a
right to choose to abandon the baby so
if a woman is pregnant and she says I
can't afford this she can terminate the
pregnancy it's her body it's her choice
the man could also be broke but he can't
say I would like to be you know removed
from financial responsibility and choose
not to have a child so basically he's
infantilizing women
oh yeah of course I mean that's
typically what the left does they say
that women aren't responsible for their
choices you're not responsible for
having sex with somebody if you had too
much to drink that's on the man even if
the man had just as much
there was a post that went up a school
that went viral several years ago where
it was like have you both had too much
to drink while you're raping her that's
right it's like you're both drunk you're
both trashed bro like especially I think
in Illinois but I think that's
infantilizing in Illinois the statute is
that rape is specifically male on female
and women can't rape like I don't think
there's no law for it
can can I mean I guess women can rape
it's hard to imagine no it it happens I
mean there was the story of that guy in
the store where the woman force fed him
Viagra or something oh my goodness yeah
I will say generally it is harder for a
woman to rape a man but it definitely
does happen especially assault but yeah
guys you are just you're oversimplifying
this a guy can be sexually attracted to
a woman and have a girlfriend and be
like I can't do this and then she can
still coerce him or force him she can
lean in his ear and say I'll accuse you
of doing something I'll claim you hit me
she can Spike his drink there's a whole
bunch of stuff there's also been there's
also been I think substantial number of
cases where a female teacher has raped a
male students right you know like if a
male student is 15 you don't have a ton
of control over your whole situation and
your teacher is you know 28 or 30 or
whatever I I think that I think the
Revelation happened I was just reading
an article about that today I think the
the real uh Epiphany for all of us here
is that women are obviously the real
perpetrators the whole time yeah wow
there you go I knew that all along or
perhaps perhaps equality means that
everyone is responsible for their own
decisions
and the outcomes and consequences of
those decisions when you talk to them
maybe I read too much Camille Paglia I
don't know when you talk to a
progressive about abortion they say well
the man made his choice he could have
chosen not to have sex and it's like but
not the woman I've heard I've heard
someone say that before I I once heard
someone say that you can choose not to
have sex in order to not get pregnant
like this is they just I've said this
before at some point left Wingers just
end up making right wing arguments but
in really inconsistent ways right that's
what was confusing to me I was like I
don't understand what your position is
like what are you opposed to and what do
you support and it's just you get these
these empty buzzwords you know it's her
decision it's her choice no matter how
many times me and Sheamus were basically
talking about the baby's body what if
the babies are girls the Babe is it her
choice Matt's answer was it's the
woman's choice and it's like the baby is
alive and being born it's the woman's
Choice like but he's like it's her body
it's like but what about the baby's body
it's like it just right over the head
not I there's no argument if you can't
argue with someone doesn't understand
what you're talking about you know makes
it hard yeah
[Laughter]
well I thought I think we we did have a
very productive conversation with Jamie
yesterday and one point he made and
again like I I mean I very much enjoyed
it and by the way I'll say this and we
talked we did it we appreciated you know
Matt coming on and being willing to have
a conversation with us and you know I
mentioned it was mostly with Tim there
was a couple moments I felt a need to
interject I didn't want it to be on two
two on one there were a few times I was
like all right I have to jump in here
because this is like blatantly correct I
need to say something but what I really
appreciated about Jamie is he clearly
disagreed with me on the pro-life issue
but I felt as if his questions were very
much in good faith and he was sort of
curious about the perspective and he
said something which was we're not
really going to get anywhere with the
dialogue if people like don't have faith
that they can reason with the person
they're talking to and they don't have
some basic empathy and understanding for
the other position
people like you by the way I just want
to say empathy for it doesn't mean it's
a good position and I agree with you
like I think I think it's completely
abhorrent to uh believe in abortion but
also at the same time like I think a lot
of people believe in it because they
just don't understand the issue that
well how can you have a a coherent
political discussion with people who
believe jussie Smollett
you can't
yeah that makes it tough like Taylor
Lorenz can write every article in the
world and people just like they stare at
it with drool coming out of their mouths
and it's like maybe this person can't
understand arguments it's so funny that
you just mentioned Jesse smell like
because I just pulled up a
post-millennial article saying flashback
Dr Oz pushed Jesse Smith yeah is that
true yeah
at least our public statements didn't we
terraz ends up coming on top of it Dr Oz
also uh was like pro-trans trans and
kids and was pro-abortion like 10
minutes ago we couldn't get Sean Parnell
I know all right man have they called it
for uh who's gonna win that it doesn't
matter McCormick versus off I don't
think they called it yet but I wanted to
mention something about Dr Oz I covered
the Pennsylvania rally I was asking
people is Dr Oz America first most
people said no one person that I spoke
to said Dr Oz is the kind of guy who's
supported by like Oprah Winfrey and like
that's why he doesn't like him and then
I responded to him you know like Trump
also supports him and Oprah originally
supported Trump too like I'm old enough
to remember when Oprah Winfrey supported
Trump's original initially when Trump
started running wasn't Hannity like the
the the Trump Whisperer for Oz it was so
like it was so weird to so many people
why Oz got that endorsement it's
interesting we're seeing like this
celebrification I don't know if we're
seeing it more I'm just paying more
attention but it's there was Trump
originally there's Dr Oz there's also I
forgot the Superstar football player
college football player in Georgia who's
running for Senate I don't remember
either he has as the gay son who's a
conservative activist too Walker Walker
Herschel Walker yeah okay he's running
for a son I believe too in Georgia so
it's interesting that we're seeing the
celebrification more celebrities
um throwing their hands
we saw that with Ronald Reagan I mean he
was famous Hollywood actor
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there